Professor Ben Polak:
Okay, so I want to set up a new
topic today, and to get us
started I thought we'd play a
game.
So the game is going to be
called cash in a hat,
and we'll see what this game is
like in a minute.
So the idea is this,
there's going to be two
players.
I'm going to pick on two of you.
I hope I can find people who
brought some money to class.
So Player I will have a choice,
Player I can put nothing,
$1 or $3 into a hat.
The hat will then be given to
Player II and Player II can look
at what's in the hat and either
she can match what's in the hat,
i.e., add the same amount in so
1 if it's 1, or 3 if it's 3,
or she can simply take the
cash.
The payoffs of this game will
be as follows.
Player I, if they put nothing
in, they're not going to get
anything.
If they put 1 in and it's
matched then they double their
money, so they get 2 back.
If they put 3 in and it's
matched then they double their
money, so they get 6 back so
they'll net 3.
However, if they put 1 in and
Player II takes it they've just
lost their dollar,
and if they put $3 in and
Player II takes it they've lost
$3.
Everyone understand that?
Pretty simple.
From Player II's point of view,
if Player II matches then they
get their investment back plus
$1.50 if they matched 1,
so the get 2.50 back in all;
and they get their investment
back plus $2 if they match 3,
so they get 5 back in all.
Of course, if they simply take
the money out of the hat and put
it in their pocket then that's
what they get in the game.
So once again,
if Player II matches with $1,
there's $1 in the hat and she
matches, then she gets back 2.50
for a profit of 1.50.
If there's $3 and she matches
3, she gets back 5 for a profit
of 2;
and if she simply takes the
money out of the hat and puts it
in her pocket then she gets how
ever much money was in the hat.
So I here will be the provider
of the hat, we'll use the same
hat we used before,
and if necessary I'll provide
sheets of paper,
we can write IOU's on,
but I'm hoping we can play for
real cash.
Later on--it would be nice to
get a chair here--but for now,
let me just go down here and
I'm going to grab this mike.
Who here wants to be Player I?
Who brought some money to class
today?
I'm quite willing to pick on
somebody.
All right good,
so Player I is,
what's your name again?
Student: Justin.
Professor Ben Polak:
Justin.
So hold onto that hat for a
second and who wants to be
Player II?
All right, so this gentleman
here whose name is?
Student: Nate.
Professor Ben Polak:
Nate.
All right so we have Justin and
So Justin you have to decide
how much money you're going to
put in the hat.
Did you bring some money too
Nate?
Better make sure you have,
otherwise borrow some from your
neighbors.
Student: I'm going to
put in a buck.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so the money's being put
in the hat and delivered to
Nate.
Student: I'm going to
put in a buck too so that I get
2.50.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so if we empty out the
hat, here's our beautiful pink
hat.
I should really have the hat
passed across the room rather
than have me do it,
but we have $2 in the hat so
I'm going to pay each - I'm
going to pay--what am I going to
pay?
I'm going to pay Player I $2,
I'm going to give them back
their original $1 and give them
$2 in a second,
and I'm going to pay Player II
$1.50.
Just hold the hat.
Student: $2.50.
Professor Ben Polak:
$2.50, you got your money back.
Trying to cheat me is that it?
So Player, I'll get you the
rest in a second,
hang on a second for now,
so we double the money.
So one reason to take this
class is, if you play well,
you get money.
All right, now let's just play
again, so we had one round of
this, let's have another round.
Who wants to be Player I now?
All right, so Katie is Player I.
Katie did you bring some money?
Student: Yeah, sure.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, and who wants to be
Player II?
Someone further away,
let's have, Steven isn't it?
Is that right.
Student: Yeah.
Professor Ben Polak: So
Steven's going to be Player II.
Did you bring some cash?
Student: I think so.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, otherwise borrow it from
your neighbors,
I have IOU's here.
So here's the hat.
You've got coins great,
so pass the hat down.
Let's see if it makes it there,
test the honesty of the class
here.
It's working its way down,
I'm going to have to,
there we go,
all the way down to Steven.
Check how much is in there.
Student: There's a
dollar in here.
Professor Ben Polak:
There's a dollar there so you
can decide whether to match or
not.
Student: Okay,
I'll match it.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so Steven's going to
match as well.
Once again, we have this time,
rather annoyingly $1 and some
coins in here,
which I will empty on the stage
to prove to everybody and I
will--all right there are coins
in here--so I'll match this in a
second and give it back to you
guys.
So everyone understand the game?
Everyone understand how this
game works?
So we're going to spend a while
discussing this.
We'd go on playing except I'd
eventually lose so much money
I'm going to run out of lunch
money and the T.A.'s would
object.
All right, so what I want to do
is I want to analyze this game.
I want to think about what this
game's about,
what's really going on here.
So first this is just a little
game involving putting some
money in a hat.
What I want to suggest to you,
that this is a toy version of a
much more important game.
This is a toy version of a game
involving a lender and a
borrower, so you could think of
our Player I's--that was Katie
on the second round and is it
Justin on the first round,
Justin on the first round.
Imagine them working in an
investment bank,
or perhaps in a venture
capitalist firm,
and what they're doing is
they're giving a loan to
somebody, some budding
entrepreneur who's come up with
a new project.
So Steven in Round 2 and who
was my budding entrepreneur in
Round 1?
What was your name?
Student: Nate.
Professor Ben Polak:
Nate in Round 1 have come up
with some budding project.
They've left Yale,
perhaps after their junior
year.
They've left early because
they've got some great idea
which is going to make them
millions.
So either it's a new mouse trap
or a new version of Facebook or
something, and they go to
the--and that's Harvard isn't
it,
so something better than a new
version of Facebook--and they go
to this venture capitalist firm.
Maybe it's some firm in New
York or maybe it's the Yale
Investment Trust or whatever,
and they explain this great
idea to them and they ask for
some money to invest in this
firm to buy machinery and to pay
early wages and so on.
The lender, the guy who works
at the venture capitalist firm,
has to decide how much money to
invest in this project.
After this money has been
invested in the project,
the person who borrowed it
faces choices.
They could go forward with
their project,
work hard, spend the money on
the things they're supposed to
spend,
or they could just disappear to
Mexico (or go back to Yale for
that matter).
There's actually something in
between they could do which is
less dramatic than disappearing
to Mexico,
they could just not work
particularly hard,
shirk, perhaps join in someone
else's project and just let the
money run down without the
lender really knowing about it.
So this is a very real problem
that some of you,
some of the budding
entrepreneur's in the room are
going to face when you leave
Yale,
and more of you,
who are going to end up working
for investment bank's,
perhaps unfortunately,
are going to face as well.
Okay so we're going to spend
the whole of today analyzing
this, but before we even start
let's notice that there's
something different about this
game,
other than its sheer triviality.
There's something different
about this game than games we've
played all the way up to the
mid-term so far.
What's different about this
game?
Can I get a mike in here?
Yes what's different?
Student: Moves aren't
simultaneous.
Professor Ben Polak: The
moves are not simultaneous.
This is a sequential move game.
Put the rules up here and bring
this down, so for the first time
we're looking at a sequential
move game and we're going to
spend most of the rest of the
term looking at sequential move
games,
or at least looking at games
that involve sequential
elements.
Now what's really,
what makes this a sequential
move game?
Let's be careful about this.
What makes it a sequential move
game is not simply that Player I
moved first and Player II moved
second,
although that's true,
what really made this a
sequential move game is that
Player II knew what Player I had
done before he got to make his
move.
It isn't the timing per se that
matters, it's going to turn out
it's the fact that Player II
could observe Player I's choice
before having to make his or her
choice that matters.
Notice, just while we're on the
subject, more than that Player I
knew this was going to be the
case.
So let's just get that down.
So in this game Player II knows
Player I's choice before she
chooses--she being Player II,
let's say before II chooses.
Second, Player I knows that
this will be the case,
and the way we dramatized this
just now is Player I put the
money in the hat,
the hat was transported across
the classroom with people very
honestly not stealing the money
to Player II,
Player II could look in the
hat, could see how much money
was in there,
before Steven or Nate had to
make that choice.
Is that right?
So how do we go about analyzing
games that have this sequential
structure?
So it turns out that a useful
way to analyze them,
and the way I want to get us
used to today already,
is to draw a tree.
So in the first half of the
class we drew a lot of matrices,
now we're going to draw trees.
For those people who haven't
seen trees before,
not a big deal.
It's an object that looks like
a tree, that's why it's called a
tree.
So let's have a look,
so in this particular game,
here is Player I making her
choice and in fact she has three
possible choices.
She can put nothing,
1 or 3 into the hat.
Player II then chooses,
although really Player II only
has choices to make if there's
some money in the hat,
and Player II has two choices
in this particular game in
either case.
Either Player II is going to
add $1 or $3 into the hat or
they're going to disappear off
to Mexico, taking our investors'
lunch money with them.
Let's put down the payoffs.
So let's put down as payoffs,
the net gains they make.
So if nothing goes in,
no one makes any money so (0,0)
will be the payoff.
If 1 is matched by 1 then the
investor, the lender doubles her
money so she makes a net profit
of 1.
If the money is taken out by
Player II then she loses 1.
Down here if II matches her
investment of 3 she doubles her
money again, so she makes a net
profit of 3, and if the money is
taken out she loses 3.
Everyone all right with that?
Let's do Player II's payoffs.
In the case in which he matches
1 he makes a net profit of 1.50.
In the case in which he just
steals the 1 he makes a net
profit of 1.
And down here,
in the case where he matches 3
he makes a net profit of 2--he
gets 5 back but he'd invested 3
to start with --,
and here if he just takes the
money out he makes a profit of
3.
So this game is just
illustrated on the board,
and for some of you this is the
first time you've seen a tree,
but I'm going to claim it isn't
such a complicated object and we
could spend a lot of time
analyzing this in terms of
connected graphs and so on,
but it isn't really worth it:
it's just a tree.
Okay, so let's just make sure
we understand that the payoffs
here represent Player I's payoff
and Player II's payoff
respectively.
So how do we analyze what to do
in these games?
It's a good idea always to
write out the tree like it's a
good idea to write out the
matrix, but how to analyze what
we should do?
Well before we do that,
let me just grab the mike and
find out from our players what
they should do.
So where was my first investor?
So Justin why did you put $1 in
there?
Student: Well if I put
$1 in then he has an incentive
to put $1 in too.
If I put in $3 he's just going
to take the money and run.
Professor Ben Polak:
Okay, so what's Justin doing?
Justin is looking forward,
if you like.
He's putting himself in Player
II's shoes.
Who was our receiver?
Nate.
Nate's shoes and anticipating
what Nate's going to do.
And, as Justin said,
if he puts in 3 Nate's going to
have an incentive to take the
money and run.
In fact, what would Nate have
done?
If 3 had been in the hat what
would you have done?
Student: I like Justin
but I would have taken the
money.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, even though you know
Justin, you would have taken the
money and disappeared somewhere,
we don't quite know right?
Is the same true for the other
player?
So Katie, you also put 1 in,
is that your explanation as
well?
Student: Same reasoning.
Professor Ben Polak:
Same reasoning,
okay.
So everyone figured out what
was going on,
and once again,
we think probably,
let's try, Steven if it had
been $3 in the hat what would
you have done?
Student: I would have
taken it.
Professor Ben Polak:
Taken it, all right.
So we're basically getting
what's predicted here out of the
game.
Let's just see that more
formally, that idea.
So the idea here is that the
players who move early on in the
game should do something we've
always talked about before.
They should put themselves in
the shoes of the other players,
but here that takes the form of
anticipation.
They're anticipating what
players down the tree are going
to do.
So the key idea here is
anticipation.
What they're going to do is
they're going to look forward
down the tree;
imagine themselves in the shoes
of the later players;
look at the incentives facing
those later players;
imagine that they do the best
they can--those later players do
the best they can --;
and then walk backwards through
the tree.
So the key idea here is to look
forward to the end of the tree
and work back:
look forward and work back.
That's exactly the process that
Katie and Justin described
themselves as doing.
Now in this tree,
let's have a go at this.
So let's imagine ourselves in
Steven or Nate's shoes,
having found--as they did in
fact--having found $1 in the
hat.
They then are making a choice
between adding $1 which nets
them a $1.50 or taking the $1
which nets them $1.
1.50 is bigger than 1,
so we think they're going to go
this way.
Everyone happy with that?
Conversely, if they found
themselves with $3 in the hat
then, if they add $3 --they
match--they're going to get $2,
they're going to net $2;
and if they take the money out
they're going to get away with
$3.
3 seems bigger than 2 so we
think they're going to go this
way.
Again, we're assuming that
these are their real payoffs.
Okay, so from Player I's point
of view, since Player I knows
that Player II will observe the
choice before making her own
choice,
and since Player I can put him
or herself in Player II's shoes
and anticipate this choice,
Player I is essentially
choosing between what?
If she puts in 0 she gets 0,
if she puts in 1 she knows II
will match and she'll double her
money and get 1,
and if she puts in 3,
then she knows Player II will
take the money and run,
in which case our lender will
have lost $3.
So she's choosing between 0,1
and -3 and she's going to choose
$1, which is exactly what
happened in the game.
Everyone happy with how we did
that?
So this idea of starting at the
last player, the player who
moves last, solving out what
they're going to and then
working our way back through the
tree has a name.
The name for this is "backward
induction."
I apologize for the
business-school students in the
room who have had this hammered
into them too many times already
so I apologize for them in
advance.
Backward induction.
Now it turns out there's
precisely one controversial
thing about backward induction,
which is whether you should say
backward induction or backwards
induction.
So I'm going to leave the "s"
off and call it backward
induction, but it's up to you
which you think the correct
English is.
Okay, so since we've got this
game here let's talk about it a
bit.
This idea of the lender and the
borrower--it's not an
unimportant situation.
We've simplified it down to a
very simple choice here,
but it's a very basic choice
out there in the real world.
It's an important choice,
after all, what keeps the
economy running is the ability
of lenders to lend money to
businesses that then invest them
profitability,
and are able to make returns.
So this underlies a whole bunch
of stuff going on in the
economy.
So let's talk about this and
the first thing I want to talk
about is, I want to point out
that there's a problem here.
There's a bad thing here,
much like there was a bad thing
in the very first class of the
semester.
In the very first class of the
semester the bad thing was a
Prisoner's Dilemma,
but here it's a little
different but let's focus on it
a while.
So the bad thing is we ended up
here.
Not a disaster:
the lender doubled her money.
The borrower was able to go
ahead with the project on a
small scale and make some money.
The bad thing,
however, is that we would have
liked to end up here.
Had we been able to have a
large project funded with $3 and
had the borrower repaid those
dollars,
so matched in effort or
whatever that happens to be,
then we'd have ended up at an
outcome that is better not just
for the lender--it's obviously
better for the lender--but it's
also better for the borrower.
Does everyone see that?
So the outcome we would like to
have reached gets the lender 3
whereas she's only getting 1
where we ended up,
and it gets the borrow 2 where
he's only getting 1.50 where we
actually ended up.
Why is it that we were unable
through both of our pairs,
both Justin and Nate,
and Katie and Steven--why were
we unable to get to here?
Any takers?
What got us,
what prevents us from getting
to this good outcome?
Let's go back to Katie a second
and see if we can,
go ahead.
I'll come it's all right.
So Katie was saying why she
invested 1.
I picked on Justin before,
so here's this good outcome,
it's better for you,
it's better for Steven who's
your borrower,
why aren't we getting to this
3,
2 outcome?
Student: Because if I
play 3, him matching my money is
dominated, strictly dominated.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so the problem here is
Katie would like to invest 3 if
she knew that in fact Steven was
going to match,
but she knows Steven's not
going to match.
Steven, in fact,
is going to run off with the
cash.
It's going to end up being
spent at Starbuck's or
something.
From Steven's point of view he
would actually like to be able
to borrow the $3.
He would like to be able to end
up at this 3,2 outcome as well.
The problem is he knows that
Katie knows, and Katie knows
that he knows,
that in fact he's going to run
off with the cash.
Is that right?
So we're in a bit of a problem
here.
We'd like to get this good
outcome but incentives are
preventing us from getting
there.
What do we call this kind of
situation?
problem?
Anybody?
No takers?
This is called "moral hazard."
How many of you have heard the
term moral hazard before?
A number of people have heard
of it.
So moral hazard here is the
problem.
That the agent,
in this case the borrower has
incentives--will have
incentives--to do things that
are not in the interests of the
principal.
If we're not careful,
for example,
by giving too big a loan,
the incentives of the borrower
will be such that they will
actually not be aligned with the
incentives of the lender and
that will prove to be bad for
the lender.
But notice the existence of
this moral hazard problem isn't
only bad for the lender.
It ends up being bad for the
borrower as well.
Let me give you another
example, in insurance there's a
classic, probably the classic
moral-hazard problem.
If an insurance company insures
me against having my car stolen,
there's a moral hazard problem
in that I might,
if the car is fully insured,
I might now have the incentive
not to bother to lock my car or
to leave it anywhere on the
street in New Haven,
because I'm not bearing the
cost.
So we need to be able to--the
insurance company needs to worry
about that in writing an
insurance contract for me.
And in practice what the
insurance company does is it
forces me to take a deductible.
It doesn't allow me full
insurance.
It makes sure that some of the
cost of having a car stolen is
going to fall on me.
That's bad for me by the way
because it means I can't get
full insurance.
And notice that what happened
here is rather similar.
In this case,
both the lender and the
borrower would rather have a big
project, a big loan,
and have the agent pay back
that loan.
They'd prefer this (3,2)
outcome, but they can't get
there.
And therefore rather than
having a full scale project,
Katie or Justin only offered
the borrowers a small scale
project.
So the idea here in this
example was--what happened was
we kept the size of the project
or the size of the loan--you can
think of this as the project if
they're borrowing
something--small to reduce the
temptation to cheat,
to reduce the temptation not to
repay the loan.
So these problems are all over
society but they're particularly
prevalent in situations
involving lenders and borrowers.
So a good question is how might
we solve this problem?
A lot of you are about to go
out and try and borrow money to
set up your projects,
run your new version of
Facebook or whatever.
And a lot more of you as we
said before, are going to end up
loaning money,
perhaps someone else's money
probably, at least for a while.
And we want to know how you
might solve this moral hazard
problem.
We've seen one way to solve it.
One way is for me to keep the
size of the project small.
What else could we do?
Let me come down and try and
have a bit of a discussion.
What else could we do?
Steven what else could we do?
You were the borrower,
what else could you do?
Student: Impose laws.
Professor Ben Polak: We
could impose laws.
Okay, so we could impose laws
much like we tried in the
Prisoner's Dilemma,
we could regulate this market.
There's going to be a little
bit of a problem we're going to
run into in regulating the law,
in using the law here.
What's the problem we're going
to run into here?
We do have laws that regulate
borrowers and lenders.
What's the law that regulates
borrowers and lenders:
bankruptcy law right?
So we have law that regulates
to some extent what lenders and
borrowers can do.
One of the things that we do in
that law is we limit the degree
to which we're allowed to punish
the borrowers.
So bankruptcy law pretty much
says we're going to put some
limit on how much Katie can
inflict pain on Steven for
running off with the lunch
money.
Steven can simply say I can't
repay, I'm bankrupt,
and he's more or less allowed
to have a fresh start.
So the law would be good here
but there's limits to what we
can do.
We could go back to the
Dickensian world of throwing
Steven in jail for not repaying
the loan, but it's tough.
There are down sides to that it
turns out.
So what else could we do?
Yeah, I'm going to have to dive
in there, so shout into the
mike.
Student: Venture
capitalist's can impose
restrictions on what the person
can do with the money.
Professor Ben Polak: So
you could try and say there's
only certain things you can do
with the money.
And, for example,
to make that credible,
what you might have to do is to
say: show me what you're going
to do with the money,
show me the receipts.
Or another thing you could say
is, I will only give you the
money if you show me exactly how
you're going to spend this.
That's a good solution.
Notice that you could regard
that as changing the order of
play.
It's a little bit like saying,
let's have the borrower have to
move first, let's have the
borrower have to commit what
their actions are going to be,
how they're going to spend the
money before--you know--show the
contracts before the lender
lends them the money.
That's a good solution,
but again there are limitations
to this solution.
What are the limitations to
that solution in the real world?
Let's go back to all of you who
are thinking about making
millions with your new Facebook,
what are the limitations to
having some contracts with the
bank, with Chase,
saying exactly how you're going
to--not only is it saying
exactly how you're going to
spend the money but actually
detailing it already with
contracts ahead of time.
What are the problems with that?
Someone else who's thinking of
going into business here--let me
pick on somebody a second.
So what's your name sir?
Student: Kelly
Professor Ben Polak:
Kelly, so imagine you have some
project,
you're going to borrow some
money from Chase or Mr.
Swenson to set up this fund,
why might you worry about
having everything written out
contractually ahead of time?
Student: I mean then it
restricts your freedom on what
your ideas are,
I guess.
Professor Ben Polak:
Right, so one problem is just
sheer lack of flexibility.
If, in fact,
the entrepreneur is not going
to be flexible on how they
actually run the project,
there's not much point of being
an entrepreneur in the first
place.
There's a limit to how much
control you want to give to the
lender.
The lenders don't really want
to run the project for you.
There's also a severe problem
of timing.
It's simply not going to be
possible to specify all the
expenditures of a project up
front.
You're going to need some money
to do some things ahead of time.
So it's a good idea--changing
the order of play is a good
idea--but there's going to be
limitations to this.
What else could you do as the
lender?
What else could you do?
Thinking of loaning some money
in here, loaning some money to
one of your classmates for some
project.
Let's try here.
Student: Something like
loan money over time in stages
and observe progress.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good, so one possibility is to
break the loan up and give
it--let it come in small
installments.
If you do well on the first
installment I'll give you a
bigger installment next time.
Notice that that's a little bit
like something we talked about
in the very first week.
It's a little bit like taking
this one shot game and turning
it into a repeated game.
It's turning a one shot
interaction into a repeated
interaction.
We'll come back and talk about
repeated interactions later on
in the course.
Again, notice that there might
be some limitations to this.
I mean I think it's a good
idea, and in general you should
be trying to do this,
but it could just be that the
set up--for Nate to set up his
new Facebook and for Steven to
set up his new mousetrap
factory--they just need a chunk
of money at the beginning.
There may be some limit to how
little money you can give them
at the beginning since they have
to hire workers,
and set up the factory,
and make some big splash in
advertising, and so on and so
forth.
So again, it's a good idea but
there may be limitations here.
What else could you do?
Let's have a look at the
numbers on the board.
Right now, the numbers on the
board say that if Steven's
mousetrap project--were you the
Facebook or the mousetrap?--if
Steven's mousetrap project goes
well and it ends up being a big
project with lots of money
available.
There are five units of money
available in profit,
3 plus 2.
The way we've designed things
so far, our lender--I gave you
these payoffs in the game--the
lender is going to double her
money.
She's going to get 6 back to
net 3 and Steven's going to get
2.
So the division of that 5 is 3
and 2.
But we don't have to divide the
money like that.
If you're a lender you may want
to think about how you divide up
the spoils of a successful
project.
So how else could you divide up
those $5, that 3 plus 2,
in a way that might be better
for everybody?
Nate?
Student: Give the
investor $3.01 if they do that
other choice and then take a
little bit of a hit but that way
you'll still have something
that's pretty optimal to the
other choices that we came to
before.
Professor Ben Polak: I'm
guessing you all didn't hear
that but that was right,
so let me just say it.
That's exactly right.
So what you could do here is
you could redesign the payoffs
of this project in the event
that it's successful.
What you could do is take these
5 units of profit and instead of
having (3,2)--let's write that
in a different color--we could
give the borrower,
the entrepreneur 3.1,
leaving 1.9 to the lender.
All right, so we could change
the payoffs of this contract to
be (1.9,3.1) in the event of a
big project.
Why does that help?
Because now our borrower,
Nate or Steven,
were they to end up with a hat
with $3 in it,
they now will find it in their
interest to match the $3 and get
3.1 rather than 3.
So what's this an example of?
This idea of changing the
contract to give the borrower
incentives to repay,
incentives not to shirk,
incentives not to disappear
with the cash,
is an example of what's called
"incentive design."
So the idea here is,
in a lot of businesses,
incentives are not given by
God.
They're designed by the people
who write the contracts.
If you're either the borrower
or the lender,
you should be thinking about
writing a contract that's going
to achieve the end that you
want.
Now notice in this particular
example, exactly as Nate said,
the lender's going to take a
bit of a hit here,
they're not going to get a 100%
return, but they're ending up
doing better than they would
have done by giving a small
loan.
They've ended up getting 1.9
rather than 1,
so in this particular
example--it won't always be the
case but in this
example--they're taking a
smaller share of a larger pie.
Sometimes a smaller share of a
larger pie is bigger than a
larger share of a smaller pie:
not always but sometimes.
The reason the pie is larger is
we're able now in an incentive
compatible way--we're able to go
ahead and have a large project.
So in this example,
the smaller share of the larger
pie actually ended up being
bigger than the larger share of
the smaller pie.
So a smaller share of a larger
pie can be bigger than a large
share of a small pie,
not always of course.
This is just an example.
Now let's just be a little bit
careful here.
So in this particular example,
even though this 1.9--this
return that our lender is able
to make by accepting a smaller
share of a larger pie--even
though it's a bigger absolute
return,
it's smaller in another sense.
In what sense is it smaller?
Let's be careful here.
We're tempted to say look it's
1.9.
1.9 is bigger than 1.
That's got to be a good thing.
But since some of you actually
are going to go out into
investment banks,
and you might be posed this
question,
let me just make sure we don't
make a blunder that's going to
spoil your interview.
So what might you be worried
about as an investment banker
about this deal,
about this contract?
Somebody else, anybody else?
I'll come down again,
that's all right.
What might you be worried about?
Who here, be honest,
who here has been interviewing
with either investment banks or
venture capital firms,
or private equity firms?
Raise your hands.
Oh come on there has got to be
more than that.
There was a hand.
Where was the hand at the back?
There was a hand way back here.
No, yeah?
What might be wrong with this
project from your point of view?
Can I get the mike on that side?
This gentleman here,
what might be wrong with the
project from your point of view?
Student: If you could
actually just find three small
projects then you could still
get a 100% returns just by
dividing it up.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good, you're going to make lots
of money for Morgan Stanley or
whatever it is,
good.
Your name is?
Brian, right so it's a good ad
to hire Brian at Morgan Stanley.
So what Brian said was it's
true that you're making a bigger
absolute return here.
This is a bigger absolute
return.
But this return up here is a
100% return on your capital.
The rate of return on capital
is higher making a 100% return
on an investment of 1,
than making a 1.9 return on an
investment of 3.
The rate of return is better in
the smaller case.
So which is the right answer?
Should we worry about the rate
of return, the 100% rate of
return or should we worry about
the absolute return?
If you're in the business of
investment banking,
who thinks we should worry
about the absolute return?
Who thinks we should worry
about the rate of return?
Who thinks it depends?
What does it depend on?
(Keep me from falling off this
thing.) Wwhat does it depend on?
Somebody said it depends.
What does it depend on?
Depends is only a good
compromise vote if you know what
it depends on.
Yeah, the gentleman here.
Student: Since an
investment banking firm only has
limited amount of money to
invest,
you want to see if you can get
a higher rate of return
investing elsewhere.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so there's two--I think
you're on the right line.
So there's two things to worry
about, one is what is your
supply of funds to invest and
the other is--what's the other
supply you are worried about as
an investment banker or venture
capitalist firm,
or a private equity investor?
What's the other supply coming
your way?
The number of projects coming
across your door.
The demand for your cash.
The supply of projects.
What we have to worry about
here is what is the true
opportunity cost of that money?
If there were very few projects
out there then you basically
just want to go down the list of
projects picking off absolute
return,
however, you go to the other
extreme if there's an infinite
supply of projects,
all coming in,
all of which will offer a 100%
return, then as our banker at
the back told us,
you should just go for three
small projects rather than one
large one.
But the question is,
which is better?
It isn't as simple as saying,
yes, we should always go for
three small projects.
There may not be three small
projects out there that offer a
100% return.
So what's going to matter here
is what's the true opportunity
cost of the capital,
and that's going to depend on
what projects are available to
you.
This was just an example of
incentive design,
just one example of incentive
design.
Let's talk about other examples
of incentive design.
Incentive design's been a lot
in the news lately.
Who else tends to have
incentive contracts other than
borrowers?
Who else out there tends to
have incentive contracts?
It's a big topic in the news
these days.
So who has incentives written
into their contracts?
Way over here,
let me run over at the risk of
blurring the camera.
So who else has incentives in
their contracts?
Student: Managers
Professor Ben Polak:
Managers all right.
So CEO's have huge incentive
clauses in their contracts,
sometimes in the form of
options.
Why do they have those
incentive clauses in their
contract?
Well there's two
interpretations of this.
One interpretation is,
it's just a bad thing and
they're just trying to screw the
world.
But there's a more moderate
view of this.
The more moderate view of this
is that those incentive clauses
in their contracts are attempts
to align the interest of the
managers with the interest of
the shareholders,
just as this contract is
attempting to align the interest
of the lender and the interest
of the borrower.
So by managers I took him to
mean CEOs, but what other kind
of managers recently in the
press,
very recently,
this weekend,
have been talking about
incentive contracts?
Way over there,
I'm caught on the wrong side as
usual.
Can I squeeze through?
I'll try and squeeze through.
Sorry.
Where was it,
where was the answer to my
question?
Here we go.
Student: Managers of
baseball teams.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so managers of sports
teams also have incentive
contracts these days:
incentives to achieve certain
levels.
Here it's not quite clear to me
exactly what's going on.
We call those incentive
contracts but you might want to
worry a little bit.
I mean do we really think that
the manager has an incentive to
lose otherwise?
So part of what's going on with
incentive contracts isn't
actually incentive contracts,
part of it is about sharing the
risk.
Particularly in the kind of
contracts that have been written
about over the weekend with Joe
Torres' contract for the
Yankees,
which he turned down,
is partly perhaps to give him
incentives to try and win,
but perhaps it's more to do
with sharing the risk among the
general manager and the manager
of the team if they don't make
it to the playoffs.
But all right,
they're still incentive
contracts and we see incentive
contracts elsewhere,
and we've seen them since the
Middle Ages.
So in the Middle Ages,
incentive contracts took a
particular form,
and the form was called two
things,
piece rates and in agriculture
it took the form of share
cropping.
What are piece rates?
Somebody, what are piece rates?
Anybody who knows what a piece
rate is?
What is share cropping?
Somebody must be from a farming
state.
Somebody out here,
the guy in orange.
Student: Share cropping
is where the landowner takes a
portion of the farmer's crop at
the end of the farming season.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so share cropping is a
contract whereby part of the
output of the farm goes to the
landowner and part is kept by
the farmer.
Going back to the Middle Ages,
part of the output would stay
with the peasant and part of it
would go to the lord of the
manor.
Piece rates are a similar idea.
Rather than paying wages to
workers, just bundles of cash,
the amount which they're paid
depends on output.
So piece rates would say if you
produce seventeen yards of cloth
then you'll get paid the revenue
that's derived from three of
those.
Both of these forms of
contracting are there partly to
create incentives.
They create incentives because
they create the incentive for
the farmer to increase yields
and they create incentives on
the part of the worker to
increase output.
So piece rates are a big part
of the story.
Incentive designs are a pretty
big topic and we don't really
have time to go into it much in
this course.
But it's worth mentioning that,
in fact, the Nobel Prize that
was won last week by those three
economists we talked about was
partly about incentive design.
So it's regarded as an
important enough topic,
the design of incentives across
society as a whole to have been
worthy of winning the Nobel
Prize,
and my guess is that there's
another Nobel Prize that's going
to come out in this same area in
the next five or ten years.
Just to make it clear,
you can have problems:
you can write incentives badly.
It's a classic story that
you've all heard of I'm sure,
that often in the provision of
public goods,
let's say bridges or highways,
or tunnels, the incentives for
the construction companies tend
to be rather badly written.
They're meant to have incentive
clauses but they never seem to
quite get them right.
It's easy to get these
incentives wrong.
Just to prove this just doesn't
happen to management,
let me just tell a story
against myself.
So a year ago,
a year and a bit ago,
I was picking fruit with my
then three year old daughter and
I wanted to make sure that we
got some fruit home to eat for
dinner,
and she didn't just eat all the
fruit as we picked it.
These were raspberries.
So I decided to have a rule
that sounds efficient.
I said any item of fruit that
gets picked that's in good
condition we'll take it home for
dinner,
but if it's squashed,
then we'll eat it then and
there while we're picking the
fruit.
So my three year old proceeded
to go along the bushes of
raspberries, picking the
raspberry,
turning around to me and saying
"squashed" and putting it in her
mouth: "squashed,"
"squashed," which shows that a
three year old knows more than a
professor about moral hazard at
some level.
So one thing we can do is worry
about incentive design in the
design of the contract.
There's another thing we can do
here.
What's the other thing we can
do here?
We're missing out on something
very basic.
What is it that our borrowers
Steven and Nate can do?
To put it more generally,
for all of you,
if you go out and start a
company,
and you borrow some money to
start your company when you
leave Yale, what are you going
to have to do?
What's the borrower--what's the
lender, what's the bank going to
insist--what is it going to
insist on?
Anybody?
They're going to insist on
collateral.
What is collateral?
I'm somewhat charmed to see how
few of you are going to end up
borrowing money,
but for those of you who
haven't got trust funds,
you're going to end up
borrowing money.
So what is collateral?
Yes, what's collateral?
Student: You give
someone the whole--You let the
bank hold onto something.
Professor Ben Polak:
Right, you let the bank hold
onto something in the event that
you default on the loan.
You're going to let the bank
hold onto something in the event
that you default on the loan.
Now for most people here,
what are they going to post as
collateral?
Let's assume that we're back to
our original contract here--we
can't do this--we're back to our
original case.
Wwhat are most of you going to
end up using as collateral if
you borrow money?
Everyone's saying a house,
I'm guessing that for most of
you --I'm not going to look
around the room because I don't
know how many trust fund babies
I've got in the room--but for
most of you,
it's going to be what?
It's going to be your parent's
house.
So why is it that your parent's
house being posted as collateral
is going to prevent you from
disappearing to Mexico with a
loan?
Well let's have a look at how
that changes the payoffs.
Now if you take the money and
run, you disappear to Mexico,
but you end up with $1 minus a
house here, and $3 minus a house
there.
Of course, we're relying here
on you liking your parents
enough not to mind about the
fact that they'll be sleeping in
the rain,
but as long as that's the case,
I think with high probability
you're now going to decide to
return the loan,
at least if you can.
Is that right?
Now notice that the way in
which this collateral works.
There's a subtlety to how this
collateral works.
You might think that the way in
which collateral works is that
now the lender feels safer,
because even if you end up
defaulting on the loan,
at least they get this house.
That's true.
There's some truth in that,
but that's really not the key
here.
Frankly, most bank lenders
don't want your parent's house.
Your parents might have very
nice houses but this isn't a
good housing market right now
and they don't particularly want
to see your parents on the
streets.
The way in which this works is
not so much that it gives an
extra positive return to the
lender,
the way in which it works is it
gives an extra negative return
to the borrower.
So let's just do this backward
induction again with the house
in place.
So with this house in place,
as before, you'll return the
loan up here,
but now provided you like your
parents enough,
you would also return the loan
here because you prefer $2 to $3
minus your parent's house,
in which case you'll get a loan
of 3.
So the way in which the
collateral worked was by hurting
you enough (or in this case
hurting your parents enough) in
the event of default,
in such a way as to change your
behavior.
But notice it helped you.
So here's a subtlety coming in
here.
By issuing collateral,
we actually lowered the payoff
of the borrower at certain end
points of the tree.
We lowered the payoff of the
borrower at certain end points
of the tree.
But as a consequence we were
able to end up at an outcome
that was better for the
borrower.
Sometimes having lower payoffs
can actually make you better
off, and the reason it makes you
better off,
is it changes the behavior of
other players in the game in
such a way as may benefit you;
in this example,
by inducing the lender to give
you a bigger loan.
So the way the collateral works
is it lowers your payoffs if you
do not repay,
but it leads to you being
better off.
The reason it makes you better
off is it changes the choices of
others in a way that helps you.
We're going to see lots of
examples of that in the next
couple of days.
Now collateral is an example,
we talked about incentive
design, collateral is also an
example of something larger.
The larger thing is the idea of
commitment.
Collateral is a commitment
strategy.
It commits you to repaying the
loan.
I want to give another example
of a commitment strategy.
I think this idea of
commitments is an important one,
and we have just about time to
do it.
So I wanted to go completely
away from our context of our
lender borrower game a second
and look somewhere else
entirely,
so we get rid of this for now.
I want to take us back to 1066,
what happened in 1066?
What happened in 1066,
I know this is America and no
one gets an education anymore,
but still, what happened in
1066?
The Norman Conquest took place
in 1066.
So the Norman Army invades from
Normandy led by William the
Conqueror and lands on the
Sussex beaches at Hastings.
What I want to imagine is a
game involving the Norman Army,
or William the Conqueror in
particular, and the Saxon Army.
So here's the little game.
So we're in the area of
medieval military strategy,
and here is the game.
We'll start with the Saxon's
here, the Norman's have already
invaded, so I guess the Norman's
have already moved but here's
the Saxon Army making a
decision.
They're deciding between
fighting and the important
medieval military tactic known
as running away.
Of course the Normans are going
to know whether the Saxons are
actually going to charge down
the beach and attack them,
and they are going to have to
decide whether to fight or run
away.
Let's put the payoffs--now
leave some space below here,
leave some space down here on
our notes--let's put the payoffs
in.
So I'm going to put the Norman
payoffs first and the Saxon
payoffs second.
Norman payoffs first,
Saxon payoffs second.
So the payoffs are going to be
like this.
If both sides fight,
a lot of people end up dead and
we'll call that (0,0).
If the Saxons fight and the
Normans run away,
the Saxons get 2 and the
Normans get 1 because at least
they're alive.
If the Saxons run away and the
Normans fight,
then the Normans get 2 and the
Saxons get 1.
I just flip things around.
And if both lots run away then
ultimately it's good for the
Saxons.
So this is the game.
Let's be careful,
I've put the Saxon payoff
second.
If we analyze this game by
backward induction we can see
that the Normans are in trouble.
Why are the Normans in trouble?
Because if they are attacked by
the Saxons then fighting yields
0 and running away yields 1,
so they're going to run away.
Conversely, if the Saxons run
away then in fact,
the Normans will stay and fight
because it's easy to stay and
fight against people who are
running away.
Even I can do that.
So they're going to go for 2
rather than 1.
But now the Saxons face this
choice, they know that if they
attack the Normans the Norman's
will run away and the Saxons
will get 2.
But if the Saxons run away then
the Norman's will stay and
fight, and the Saxons will only
get 1.
So the Saxons are going to end
up fighting.
Everyone see how we did the
backward induction?
So this is not a good situation
if you happen to be the Norman
commander, if you're the guy who
led these troops across the
channel.
So what did William the
Conqueror do?
He burned his ships.
So let's now make this game a
little bit more like the real
historical situation,
here's a move that William the
Conqueror, the King of the
Normans can do.
He can either not burn his
ships or he can burn them.
If he burns them then the game
is rather different.
Once again, the Saxons can
decide whether to fight or run
away, but now the Normans really
don't have any choice.
They have to stay and fight
because swimming back to France
wearing armor is difficult.
So the payoffs become (0,0) and
(2,1) as before.
So we know now that the Normans
are going to stay and fight.
That's all that's available to
them.
I've put it that they don't
even have the option of running
away.
If you want,
you could put running yields
them minus infinity or whatever
it is to get drowned.
So now if the Saxons,
if the Norman's have burnt the
boats, the Saxons know that if
they fight the Saxons will get
0,
if they run away they'll get
-1, so now they'll run away.
Then from William the
Conqueror's point of view,
what's he choosing between?
He knows that if he doesn't
burn his boats the Saxons will
fight, and his troops will run
away.
But if he does burn his boats,
the Saxons will run away and
his troops will fight so he
wants to burn his boats.
Everyone okay with the example?
Now this is probably the
classic example of a commitment
strategy.
William the Conqueror,
in this example,
or Cortez in perhaps the more
famous example,
burned the boats to get rid of
some strategies,
to get rid of some choices
altogether.
And you might think how can
getting rid of choices make me
better off?
The reason, in a game,
particularly in a sequential
game, in a game generally,
the reason getting rid of
choices can make me better off
is it changes the behavior of
people on the other side of the
game in such a way as benefits
me.
In this particular example,
it makes the other side less
likely to fight.
So once again this is a
commitment and the way it works
is--this example of a commitment
is actually to have fewer
options and it changes the
behavior of others.
If it didn't change the
behavior of others it wouldn't
be worth doing.
So let's just talk about this a
little bit more.
There's another famous example
of a military commitment
strategy.
It occurs in the movie Dr.
Strangelove.
How many of you have seen the
movie Dr.
Strangelove?
How many of you have not seen
the movie Dr.
Strangelove?
Good homework exercise for the
weekend: rent the movie Dr.
Strangelove.
It's a very good movie.
Stanley Kubrick I think.
So in Dr.
Strangelove,
there's a famous commitment
strategy.
What is the famous commitment
strategy in Dr.
Strangelove?
Somebody?
Let's get a mike.
Ale can we get a mike down here?
There's one on the way.
The guy in white, there you go.
Student: They lose radio
contact with the base,
which means that they're going
to end up dropping the bomb.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, that's true.
I was thinking of something
more deliberate.
What's the more deliberate--the
guy in red--while you're there,
somebody in red here.
Here we go.
Student: The Soviets
construct a doomsday device so
if they're attacked they
automatically launch all of
their nuclear weapons.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good, so the worry that the
Soviets have is they think the
Americans might attack them,
and they worry that the
Americans might attack them
thinking that they won't
retaliate,
because they won't really have
any incentive to retaliate once
their cities are destroyed.
So they construct a device they
called the doomsday device that
will automatically launch
nuclear missiles back on the
Americans if the Russians are
attacked.
It's a commitment device to
make it credible that they will
actually respond were they to be
attacked by the crazy Americans.
So there's a mistake,
however, that the Russians
make.
What is the mistake that the
Russians make?
The guy in the Yale sweatshirt
here.
Student: They don't tell
anyone about the machine.
Professor Ben Polak:
Right, they don't tell the
Americans that they've built the
doomsday device.
So this is really an important
idea hidden in what's really a
great movie.
Commitment strategies are a
good idea.
They can make things credible.
But the only reason that having
fewer strategies is good for you
is because it changes the
behavior on the other side.
In this case,
it changes the behavior of the
Saxons.
It doesn't work if the other
side doesn't know about it.
It's crucial that the other
side knows.
So the other players must know.
Just to hammer this home,
notice that the expression in
the English language is "burning
your boats."
It's not "going over to your
boats and quietly drilling a
little hole in them," it's
burning your boats.
You want the other side to see
this big bonfire on the beach
and to know that the boats are
no longer available.
Just as in Dr.
Strangelove,
it's crucial,
and it's a terrible mistake for
the Russians not to tell the
Americans that they've built
this machine.
So knowledge here is crucial,
knowledge of the other side.
Now I should just complete the
history of this.
This didn't work in the case of
the Battle of Hastings.
The Saxons attacked anyway and
it just turned,
it was a big blood bath,
and the Normans really only won
this battle because somebody got
a lucky shot and hit King Harold
in the eye.
So this is a good story but as
a military tactic not actually a
true story.
I'm adding that in,
because otherwise I'm going to
get hundreds of letters from
people who watched the video.
Now we've had a bunch of
lessons today,
but I'm not done,
I want to play one more game.
Before I do though I want to
make sure we understand--we're
going to play another game so
everybody stay put.
I want to make sure.
There's a bunch of lessons on
the board, and I want you to
understand what's important and
what's more important.
Everything is important,
but some things are more
important.
So the idea of commitment is an
important idea,
and the idea of incentive
design is an important idea,
but there's one idea here that
is more important than anything
else, and that idea is backward
induction.
I'll put a little sun around it
okay.
How important is backward
induction?
Backward induction is the most
important thing I'm going to
teach you in the second half of
the semester.
It's probably the most
important thing I'm going to
teach you in the whole semester,
and it may be the most
important thing you're going to
learn at Yale.
It's the answer to all
questions.
If I ask you a question,
and, as happens from time to
time, you've been sleeping in
class and you wake up startled
because I've now asked you a
question,
and that camera is on you,
and you don't know what the
question is, then the answer is
backward induction.
I'm stressing this because six
weeks from now,
whatever it is,
in December,
there's going to be a final
exam and I guarantee now that
there will be a question on the
final exam that involves
backward induction,
and I guarantee that at least
one person in the room will
forget to solve it by backward
induction.
So are you going to use
backward induction on the final
exam?
Yes, you're all going to
remember it.
Okay good, now we'll play one
more game just for fun.
But before we play one more
game, I'll do one other thing,
sorry one other thing before we
play one more game,
I apologize.
The one other thing I want to
do here is I put up a tree here
but I forgot to tell you
anything about the tree.
This was a tree,
and I would be remiss if I
didn't tell you a few things
about trees.
So there's a certain amount of
jargon that goes along with
trees, and I want you to go home
and read the textbook and know
what that jargon is.
So these spots,
these dots in the tree,
these things are called nodes.
And in fact the end points of
the tree where the payoffs are,
these are also called nodes but
they're called end nodes.
These branches in the tree,
the branches,
here they are,
the branches are called edges.
So a tree consists of nodes,
edges, and these missing dots
are the end nodes.
The end nodes are associated
with payoffs.
Do we need to write that?
That's obvious right:
they're associated with
payoffs.
And every other node belongs to
somebody whose turn it is to
make a decision at that node.
These other nodes,
the ones that aren't end nodes
are called decision nodes.
It's perfectly possible,
for example,
in our Norman Conquest game,
for somebody to have several
nodes.
Somebody could move once and
then later on again.
There may be also nodes that
are never reached in a game.
One last piece of jargon,
a route through a tree,
from the beginning to an end is
called a path,
a way of getting through the
tree from beginning to end.
So we'll have a pop quiz on the
jargon later and now let's play
the last game I want to play.
We've got ten minutes right?
Everyone understand the jargon?
I want to play a game now.
So the game we're going to play
is a game we're going to call
the "Hungry Lion Game."
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to pick on a row of the
class, actually I'm going to
pick on this row of the class,
and this row of the class,
everyone can see this row?
From up there,
lean over the balcony.
This row of the class,
we're going to imagine that
everybody in this row is a lion.
Do they all look like lions?
Not much, but never mind.
Pretend their lions:
suspension of disbelief.
They're all lions and they're
all hungry except for one
person, who's this guy at the
end whose name is?
So Alex is a sheep.
Alex had the misfortune of
wandering into this pack
of--pride of lions and is liable
to get eaten because they're
hungry.
However, one thing stands
between Alex the sheep and being
eaten.
The one thing that stands
between him and being eaten is
that in lion society,
the only lion who is allowed to
eat the sheep is the head lion,
the big lion whose name is
Ryan.
Ryan is the head lion here.
Only Ryan can eat Alex the
sheep.
No other lion can eat Alex the
Now there's a catch if Ryan
eats Alex--if Ryan the lion eats
Alex the sheep.
The catch is,
that if Ryan the lion eats Alex
the sheep, then Ryan the lion
will fall into a postprandial
stupor,
fall asleep,
at which point the second
largest lion whose name is Chris
can eat Ryan.
Now notice Chris can never eat
the sheep.
He can only ever eat the lion,
the big lion,
and only then if the lion has
eaten the sheep and falls
asleep.
This is very strict.
Lion society is very
hierarchical like England.
If, however,
Ryan the lion eats Alex the
sheep, and is then eaten,
falls asleep and is then eaten
by Chris the lion,
then and only then he will fall
into a stupor at which point he
can be eaten by Isabella,
who's the third largest lion
and so on.
Everyone understand the game?
No questions,
no talking among yourselves.
Write down what you would do if
you were our key decision maker,
who is Ryan the lion.
But before we write it down can
I get Alex to stand up a second,
stand up, camera on him,
this is the menu.
Thank you.
So you have to write down in
your notepad whether,
you, Ryan the lion,
in Ryan's shoes or paws or
whatever, whether you would eat
Alex the sheep.
Everybody written something
down?
Let's ask Ryan the lion what
he's going to do,
so Ryan are you going to eat
Alex the sheep?
Student: No.
Professor Ben Polak: He
says no, he's not going to eat
it, why not?
Student: Well then
because I would be eaten as
well.
Professor Ben Polak:
Then he'd be eaten.
Well let's see if he would have
been eaten.
So had he eaten Alex the sheep,
then he would have fallen
asleep, and then he'd have been
in danger of being eaten by
Chris.
Chris would you have eaten Ryan?
Student: No.
Professor Ben Polak: So
he wouldn't have eaten him in
fact.
In fact, it looks like Ryan
would have got a free lunch.
There are no free lunches in
Economics, so something's wrong.
Why is Chris worried about it?
Chris is worried about it
because--Chris is worried about
Isabella eating him,
and what am I doing wrong?
What's wrong with this analysis?
By the way, before we say
what's wrong,
how many of you in Ryan's shoes
would have eaten the sheep?
How many of you would not have
eaten the sheep?
Okay, what am I doing wrong?
I'm in totally the wrong part
of the room.
I shouldn't be here at all.
I shouldn't be at all in this
part of the classroom.
I can't get around.
Wait a second.
Excuse me.
I should be,-- which row were
my lions?
Where's my lion row?
I should be way over here with
the baby lion,
whose name is Agay.
So Agay is a little baby
lion--very cute--but Agay,
if he gets a chance to eat is
going to eat.
Why is he going to eat?
Because there's no one to eat
him.
So if Agay gets the chance to
eat the second babiest lion
whose name is John,
then Agay will eat.
So if John gets a chance to eat
Ben, is John going to eat Ben?
John are you going to eat Ben?
No, John's not going to eat Ben
because John knows he'll get
eaten by Agay.
So Ben, if you get a chance to
eat Vidur, are you going to eat
Vidur?
Wait a second.
We just argued that if you eat
then the second largest lion
whose name was John is not going
to eat you.
Yes.
So we know the littlest lion is
going to eat.
So the second littlest is not
So the third littlest lion can
eat safely.
So the fourth littlest lion
should not eat.
So the fifth littlest lion
should eat.
We've got eat,
not eat, eat,
not eat,
eat, not eat,
eat, is that right?
So in fact he should have eaten
him, but the more important
point is how should we have
analyzed this game?
What should we have used?
Backward induction.
How many of you used backward
induction?
Be honest, so what's the point
here?
The point is this:
five minutes ago I said the
most important thing you'll ever
learn at Yale is backward
induction,
then I distracted you with some
fairly irrelevant nonsense,
and five minutes later nobody
used backward induction.
So the main lesson from today,
this is where we're going to
pick up on Wednesday is to use
something, what are we going to
use?
Backward induction.
All right we'll see you on
Wednesday.